This reporter named Eric Mennel told me this thing a little while back that I found totally fascinating, knew nothing about at all. Eric was raised as an evangelical in Florida and works these days at Gimlet Media. And he's been reporting on this one part of the Christian world for a while.
一位名叫埃里克·门内尔（Eric Mennel）的记者前阵子告诉我一件我完全着迷、且此前闻所未闻的事情。埃里克在佛罗里达州的一个福音派家庭长大，目前在 Gimlet Media 工作。一段时间以来，他一直在报道基督教世界里的一个特定领域。
There's this whole Christian version of Silicon Valley, only instead of, like, creating apps and tech products, what the Christian world is trying to do is use the tools of Silicon Valley to create churches. They'll call them church startups or church plants.
基督教世界里存在一个硅谷式的版本，只是他们不是在开发应用程序或科技产品，而是试图利用硅谷的手段来创建教会。他们称之为“教会创业”或“教会植堂”。
And so what are some of the tools that they use that are the same?
那么，他们使用的哪些工具与硅谷相同呢？
It kind of runs the gamut, right? If you can find it in Silicon Valley, it probably exists somewhere in the church planting world. So for example, there are boot camps, where, for maybe three or five days of your time, you can go and learn everything that you need to learn in order to start a new church.
种类繁多，应有尽有，对吧？如果你能在硅谷找到的东西，它很可能也存在于教会植堂的世界里。举个例子，有那种训练营，你只要花三到五天的时间，就能学到创立新教会所需的一切知识。
Mhm.
嗯。
They have these big incubators, right? Like, there's one in New York City, where, over the course of two years, you'll come to get this product off the ground-- this product, of course, being your church. And the same way that tech companies are obsessed with their origin stories-- one thing you hear a lot is how they've gotten their start in garages-- church plants have their own origin stories.
他们有大型孵化器，对吧？比如纽约市就有一个，你可以在两年内让这个“产品”问世——当然，这个产品就是你的教会。正如科技公司热衷于讲述他们的起源故事一样——你经常听到他们说自己是在车库里起家的——教会植堂也有他们自己的起源故事。
Over two decades ago, my wife, Amy, and I started Life Church in what was then a little two-car garage.
二十多年前，我和妻子艾米（Amy）在当时一个只能停两辆车的车库里创办了“生命教会”（Life Church）。
That's from a video off one of these churches' websites. They also have conferences.
那段视频来自这些教会之一的网站。他们也举办会议。
We're going to go ahead and get started. Glad you're here. We'll give you one minute. Kind of our background--
我们马上要开始了。很高兴你们来到这里。我们给你们一分钟时间。谈谈我们的背景——
So this is a session at the biggest church planting conference in the country. It happens every year in Orlando. It's called Exponential. It's sort of the TechCrunch Disrupt of church planting.
这就是全国最大的教会植堂会议上的一场会议。它每年在奥兰多举行，名为“指数级”（Exponential）。它有点像是教会植堂界的 TechCrunch Disrupt 大会。
So we ease-- again, our goal, our target, is unchurched people, high-conversion growth rate. So we're targeting them. So we're easing them in to the process of church. Now, there's two gathering models, if you will.
所以，我们——再次强调，我们的目标是未去过教会的人群，实现高转化率的增长。所以我们要针对他们。我们要引导他们慢慢进入教会的过程。现在，如果可以的话，这里有两种聚会模式。
So this sounds so jargony-- like, high-conversion growth rate means they're trying to convert non-church people into church people?
这听起来太像行话了——比如说，高转化率是指他们试图把不去教会的人变成去教会的人吗？
Yeah. It's really interesting. You actually kind of see this, like, blending of techy jargon with Christian jargon in this world. Like, in this particular seminar, they talk about "kingdom return on investment." Or "evangelistic networking" is one I've read, or "corporate renewal dynamics."
是的。这非常有趣。在这个领域，你实际上可以看到科技术语和基督教术语的融合。比如，在这个特定的研讨会上，他们谈论“王国投资回报率”。我还读到过“福音派网络化”或“企业更新动力学”。
"Launch" is a big word that they use in both worlds. They talk about "launch Sundays" and "launch budgets" in church planting. And the framing of what they're doing is in business terms, right?
“启动”（Launch）是他们在两个领域都常用的一个大词。他们谈论教会植堂中的“启动周日”和“启动预算”。他们所做的事情的框架都是用商业术语来表述的，对吧？
This is a story about--
这是一个关于——
This is from a website from one of the gurus of this movement. His name is Tim Keller. I've actually heard one pastor call him the Yoda of church planting.
这来自该运动的一位大师的网站。他的名字叫蒂姆·凯勒（Tim Keller）。我实际上听过一位牧师称他为教会植堂界的尤达（Yoda）。
Uh-huh.
嗯哼。
He founded this incredibly successful church in New York City called Redeemer Presbyterian church. And it's also formed its own church planting organization called Redeemer City to City. So this is a video about planting more churches in New York City, and it's described entirely through business terms.
他在纽约市创办了一家非常成功的教会，叫救赎主长老会（Redeemer Presbyterian church）。它还成立了自己的教会植堂组织，叫“救赎主城市到城市”（Redeemer City to City）。这是一段关于在纽约市建立更多教会的视频，它完全是通过商业术语来描述的。
In 1989, New York was the least religious city in America. Less than 1% of center-city New Yorkers attended a gospel teaching church. Today, that number is 5%.
1989年，纽约是美国最不信教的城市。不到1%的纽约市中心居民参加福音派教会。今天，这个数字是5%。
These are their own numbers, by the way. And in the video, a dot is moving up the graph.
顺便说一下，这些是他们自己的数据。视频里，一个点正在图表上向上移动。
We are launching a 10-year vision to see the body of Christ in New York rise from 5% to 15%. That means tripling by 2026. And here's the thing. We think that just might represent a tipping point-- a tipping point of gospel saturation that does more than just--
我们正在发起一个十年的愿景，旨在看到纽约的基督身体从5%增长到15%。这意味着到2026年翻三倍。关键在于，我们认为这可能代表一个引爆点——一个福音饱和的引爆点，其作用不仅是——
OK, so in the tech world, the investors are these VC firms, Venture Capital firms. What's the equivalent in this world?
好吧，在科技界，投资者是那些风险投资公司。那么在这个领域，对应的角色是什么？
So a lot of the startup capital comes from the biggest denominations. The Southern Baptists-- they spend tens of millions of dollars a year on church planting. But a lot of church plants actually get their funding directly from megachurches-- established churches that have thousands of members. They view it as their mission to launch new, successful churches.
很多启动资金来自最大的教派。美南浸信会每年在教会植堂上花费数千万美元。但许多教会植堂实际上直接从大型教会——拥有数千名成员的成熟教会——获得资助。他们将启动新的、成功的教会视为自己的使命。
And how long has this been happening?
这种情况持续多久了？
Church planting, in its modern form, started about 20 or 30 years ago. And they came about to solve what is basically a business problem. Since the 1970s, the number of people who've said they are going to church at least once a week has dropped 40%, according to the best data on this. That's from the National Opinion Research Center at the University of Chicago. And it's been especially bad among young people in their late teens and 20s. The percentage of 20-somethings who claim no religious affiliation has doubled since 1996.
现代形式的教会植堂始于大约20或30年前。它们的出现是为了解决一个本质上的商业问题。据芝加哥大学国家民意调查中心提供的最佳数据显示，自1970年代以来，每周至少去一次教会的人数下降了40%。在十几岁到二十几岁的年轻人中情况尤为严重。自1996年以来，声称没有宗教信仰的20多岁人群的比例翻了一番。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah, from 20% to almost 40%. And these churches have recognized that without young people, they simply cannot survive. So they wanted to get nonbelievers coming to church.
是的，从20%增加到近40%。这些教会意识到，如果没有年轻人，他们根本无法生存。所以他们想吸引不信教的人来教会。
And to do that, what they've tried to do is disrupt the way evangelical church is usually done. So they'll meet in weird, lean, hipper spaces. They'll have better music.
为了做到这一点，他们试图打破传统的福音派教会运作方式。所以他们会在奇怪、简朴、更潮的空间里聚会。他们会提供更好的音乐。
And has that worked?
那成功了吗？
Yeah, it's worked. When you look at church attendance, one of the only groups that aren't seeing drastically falling numbers are evangelicals-- the group that has focused most seriously on church planting.
是的，成功了。当你观察教会出席率时，唯一没有看到数字急剧下降的群体之一就是福音派——这个最认真专注于教会植堂的群体。
And Eric, you are here today to tell this story. You have spent months following somebody who's trying to attract funders and start one of these church plant startup churches.
埃里克，你今天来这里是为了讲述这个故事。你花了好几个月的时间跟踪一个正试图吸引资助者并建立其中一家植堂创业教会的人。
Yes, yes. His name is Watson Jones III. Watson is 34. He's bald. He has a clean beard and thick-rimmed glasses. He grew up going to a traditional Baptist Church on the south side of Chicago. And he knew that he wanted to start a church, even since he was a teenager.
是的，是的。他的名字叫沃森·琼斯三世（Watson Jones III）。沃森今年34岁。他光头，留着干净的胡子，戴着粗框眼镜。他在芝加哥南区的一家传统浸信会教会长大。甚至从十几岁起，他就知道自己想创办一家教会。
So he did all the things you're supposed to do to become a pastor. He went to seminary. He got a master's in divinity. And from the beginning, he had a real gift for preaching. This is from a sermon he gave while he was still in training.
所以他做了所有成为牧师该做的事。他去了神学院。他获得了道学硕士学位。从一开始，他在讲道方面就非常有天赋。这是他在接受培训时所做的一次布道。
Remember growing up on the south side of Chicago, and my daddy was teaching me how to ride a bike. Your parents ever walked alongside of you while you riding that bike? And I remember, we were going down the street, and I saw some girls on the porch.
记得小时候在芝加哥南区，我爸爸教我骑自行车。你们的父母有没有在你骑车时走在你身边？我记得，我们沿着街道走，我看到门廊上有一些女孩。
Oh, yeah. You know, when you see them girls on the porch, you got to get it together. Can't have your parent holding your hand now. You got to straighten up and fly right.
哦，是的。你知道，当你看到门廊上的那些女孩时，你得表现得像样点。现在不能让你爸牵着你的手了。你得挺直腰板，表现出色。
I said, Daddy, get your hands off the handlebars, man. I got this.
我说，爸爸，把你的手从车把上拿开，伙计。我可以搞定。
[AUDIENCE LAUGHING]
[观众笑声]
And it didn't take me too long to get to a point where I realized, I never learned how to balance myself without my daddy's help. Here it is-- some of us are busy slapping Jesus' hands off the handlebars of our life. There are many of us--
没过多久，我就意识到，如果没有我爸爸的帮助，我根本学不会如何保持平衡。就是这样——我们中有些人正忙着把耶稣的手从我们生活的车把上拍掉。我们中有许多人——
And Watson really knew nothing about the church planting world until a friend clued him into some of this, told him about a boot camp that Watson then attended. But Watson didn't understand it was this entire movement-- not until he went to a conference. This was in 2013.
沃森在朋友向他透露之前，对教会植堂世界一无所知，他告诉了他一个沃森后来参加的训练营。但沃森直到参加了一次会议才明白这是一个完整的运动。那是在2013年。
He went to that big conference in Orlando, Exponential. It was eye opening. It was really exciting to him.
他去了奥兰多的那场大型会议，“指数级”。那让他大开眼界。他感到非常兴奋。
Some of what I was seeing was so new to me. It was so different. They were wearing skinny jeans and they looked real cool. And I felt like, in my background, we still wearing suits.
我所看到的一些东西对我来说太新了。太不一样了。他们穿着紧身牛仔裤，看起来很酷。我觉得，在我的背景里，我们还是穿着西装。
And I felt like people in those conferences were talking about things that helped relate with people who were not used to going to church. I felt like they were on the cutting edge. I believed that the only people who were effective were church planters. And the rest of these churches, that they need to close, or they need to adapt to all of that.
我觉得那些会议里的人谈论的事情有助于与那些不习惯去教会的人建立联系。我觉得他们走在时代前沿。我相信只有那些教会植堂者才是有效的。剩下的那些教会，要么需要关闭，要么需要适应所有这些变化。
He did notice something else when he was there at the conference, something that was also very similar to Silicon Valley.
他在会议上确实注意到了另一件事，这也是与硅谷非常相似的一点。
There were at least 4,000 in the room. And I saw a lot of white people. You know, I'd be the only black in the room, because it wasn't really a black thing more than it was a white evangelical thing.
房间里至少有4000人。我看到很多白人。你知道，我是房间里唯一的黑人，因为这与其说是黑人的事情，不如说是白人福音派的事情。
That's true in general for this movement. In the United States, it's mostly white evangelicals doing this. And they're mostly planting churches in the suburbs, or affluent or gentrifying areas in cities.
对于这项运动来说，这通常是事实。在美国，主要是白人福音派在做这件事。他们大多在郊区，或者城市中富裕或正在士绅化的地区建立教会。
So Watson wanted to do things the way these white church planters were doing them. But he wanted to fill the church with people like him-- people of color who lived in the inner city. And that difference was, to use tech world language, his competitive advantage. That was the thing that set him apart from thousands of other evangelicals looking for investors.
所以沃森想用这些白人植堂者的方式做事。但他想让自己的教会里充满像他一样的人——住在市中心、有色人种。用科技界的语言来说，这种差异是他的竞争优势。这就是他从成千上万寻找投资者的福音派中脱颖而出的原因。
I saw myself practically dancing between two lines-- between the white church and the black church. I danced in the black church because it was my identity, but danced in the evangelical world because that's where a lot of financial partners were.
我看到自己在白人教会和黑人教会之间的两条线上跳舞。我在黑人教会里跳舞，因为那是我的身份，但在福音派世界里跳舞，因为那里有许多财务合作伙伴。
And so, as you're about to hear, Watson jumps into it, like a proper pastoral entrepreneur, to build his church. And some of what that involves is not so different from starting any business, of course. And some of it is very particular to bringing people to God.
正如你即将听到的，沃森像一个正经的牧师创业者一样跳了进去，建立他的教会。当然，这其中涉及的一些事情与创办任何企业并无不同。其中一些是非常特别的，是为了引领人们归向神。
It's a funny mix where you are taking charge of things, right? You're marching to this future like you can make a difference, while all along, there's this weird powerlessness to it. Like, at some point, no matter what you do, no matter how hard you work, how hard you think about it, people either show up or they don't show up. Either they love your thing or they don't love your thing.
这是一个有趣的组合，你负责掌控事情，对吧？你向着未来进军，仿佛你能有所作为，但同时，这种过程中又有一种奇怪的无力感。就像在某个时刻，无论你做什么，无论你多么努力，无论你多么用心地思考，人们要么出现，要么不出现。要么他们喜欢你的东西，要么不喜欢。
It's like that saying from Field of Dreams-- if you build it, they will come. The real-life version of that usually has a question mark at the end of it. If you build it, will they come?
就像《梦幻之地》里的那句名言——只要你盖好了，他们就会来。现实生活中的版本通常会在后面加个问号。如果你盖好了，他们真的会来吗？
Today on our show, we have stories about people building stuff and wondering exactly that. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. And we're just going to jump right in with Act One...
今天在我们的节目中，我们有关于人们建立事物并怀疑这一点的故事。来自芝加哥 WBEZ 电台，这是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。我们直接进入第一幕……
Act One, Come All Ye Faithless. So Eric Mennel, in this act, explains what happened when Watson started his years-long quest to build his church and all the things that he could only learn the hard way.
第一幕，来吧，所有的不信者。所以埃里克·门内尔在这一幕中，解释了沃森开始他那漫长的教会建设之旅时发生了什么，以及他只能通过艰难困苦才能学到的东西。
Part of what's impressive about the church planting world is how thoroughly it tries to prepare its pastors for what's ahead. When he was first getting started, Watson enrolled in this sort of boot camp called Fellowship Associates. They flew him to Arkansas every two weeks for a few days to train.
教会植堂界令人印象深刻的部分在于它非常彻底地试图为牧师们的前路做准备。刚开始时，沃森报名参加了一个叫“团契同工”（Fellowship Associates）的训练营。他们每两周让他飞往阿肯色州几天进行培训。
They teach you everything, from fundraising, to developing a core team, to writing a philosophy of ministry, which is basically a business prospectus, to crafting a budget, to funding the budget, to managing donors, to gathering people around a vision and an idea.
他们教你一切，从筹款到开发核心团队，到编写事工哲学（基本上是一份商业计划书），再到制定预算、为预算筹资、管理捐赠者，以及围绕一个愿景和想法来聚集人们。
Fellowship Associates set Watson up with a year-and-a-half-long residency at a church plant like the one he wanted to create in a poor neighborhood in North Philadelphia, where Watson learned the nuts and bolts of a daily church operation. One of the main things to accomplish during the residency was working out a business plan. And I mean that literally-- a business plan, a clear idea for his church that he could pitch to raise money, with a clear, simple mission.
“团契同工”为沃森安排了为期一年半的驻点实习，地点在费城北部一个贫困社区的教会植堂项目，就像他想创办的那种教会一样。沃森在那里学习了教会日常运作的具体细节。在实习期间要完成的主要事情之一是制定商业计划。我的意思是字面上的——一份商业计划，一个他可以向人推介以筹集资金的清晰构思，以及一个清晰、简单的使命。
We want to create a church that will seek to reach people who don't know Jesus Christ or who are not a part of a church.
我们要创办一个教会，旨在接触那些不认识耶稣基督或不属于任何教会的人。
Part one of the pitch-- location. He'd stick with his vision to serve the kind of neighborhood church planters don't usually go into. For decades, when church painters went into urban neighborhoods, they usually picked gentrifying ones or wealthier ones. Watson chose an area on Philly's northwest side that was not gentrifying. It was mostly black, mostly low income.
推介的第一部分——地点。他将坚持自己的愿景，服务于教会植堂者通常不去的那种社区。几十年来，当教会植堂者进入城市社区时，他们通常选择士绅化或更富裕的社区。沃森选择了费城西北部一个没有士绅化的地区。那里主要是黑人，主要是低收入人群。
I am a product of the South Side of Chicago. My whole life has been living and navigating as a black Chicagoan on the South Side. That was core to me. So I really wanted to target the thoroughly urban Philadelphian, to engage people who Jesus would engage. Jesus was willing to be associated with prostitutes and with tax collectors.
我是芝加哥南区的产物。我的整个人生都是在芝加哥南区作为一名黑人生活和导航。这对我很重要。所以我真的想把目标锁定在彻底的城市费城人身上，去接触耶稣会接触的人。耶稣愿意与妓女和税吏交往。
I had the idea of whosoever, we'll let them come. Whoever wants to be a part of our church can be a part of our church. Then I also wanted to be able to reach people that were in my age group initially-- at the time, I was 28, 29, 30-- and then also trying to reach older people-- my mother's generation, which is a little more stable, so--
我有一个想法，就是“凡愿意的人”，让他们来。任何想成为我们教会一部分的人都可以加入。然后我还想先接触我这个年龄段的人——当时我28、29、30岁——同时也试着接触年长的人——我母亲那一代，他们比较稳定，所以——
So that was part one of the pitch-- location. Part two of the pitch-- the building, or lack thereof. They wouldn't have a building. This is a strategy that had been really successful for planting churches elsewhere, in well-off or gentrifying neighborhoods. They don't meet in an actual church.
这就是推介的第一部分——地点。推介的第二部分——建筑物，或者说缺乏建筑物。他们不会有建筑物。这是一种在其他地方（在富裕或士绅化社区）建立教会非常成功的策略。他们不在真正的教会里聚会。
The idea is that the church buildings carry a lot of cultural baggage. They can be stodgy and uncomfortable. So to get away from all that, and as a sort of hack to save money early on, church plants will scrap the building. In most places, this is church planting 101.
这个想法是教会建筑物承载了很多文化负担。它们可能死板且不舒服。为了摆脱这一切，也作为一种省钱的技巧，教会植堂会放弃建筑物。在大多数地方，这是教会植堂入门知识。
I said, man, churches spend too much time focusing on a building. And they put so much money into a building. So early, early, early on, I wasn't thinking anything about owning a building.
我说，老兄，教会花太多时间在建筑物上了。他们把太多的钱投进建筑物里。所以很早很早很早以前，我就没想过拥有建筑物的事。
He figured they could meet in a coffee shop, or a bookstore, or something, even his living room. And finally, part three of the pitch-- a business partner.
他认为他们可以在咖啡店、书店或某个地方聚会，甚至是他的客厅。最后，推介的第三部分——商业伙伴。
No, OK, I'm going to give you a picture of myself at this point, OK? You ready?
不，好吧，我现在给你描述一下当时的自己，好吗？准备好了吗？
This is AJ Smith.
这是 AJ·史密斯（AJ Smith）。
I'm this white kid with dreadlocks all the way down my back, with a scraggly beard, wearing moccasins with holes in them, pants that have been patched up a million times, flannels ripped up.
我是一个白人孩子，留着长到背后的脏辫，留着乱蓬蓬的胡子，穿着破了洞的鹿皮鞋，穿着打了几百万次补丁的裤子，穿着撕烂的法兰绒衬衫。
Now, AJ, a good day for him is to go sit in the mountains and just sit there by himself. That's a good day for him. That's kind of how he dressed.
现在，对 AJ 来说，美好的一天是去山上，一个人坐着。这对他就很好了。他穿衣服就是那样的。
Crunchy dude.
一个特立独行的家伙。
Yeah, no, yeah. But he was a nice guy.
是的，不，是的。但他是个好人。
AJ actually brought a lot more than just worn-out moccasins to the table. He was training at a church nearby to plant a church in the inner city. He's 31 now, and he had grown up in a church plant.
AJ 带来的远不止破烂的鹿皮鞋。他正在附近的一家教会接受培训，计划在市中心建立一个教会。他现在31岁，是在一个教会植堂项目中长大的。
He'd gone to seminary. He'd run a homeless ministry. Once you got past the dreadlocks, AJ seemed like a great number-two guy. And he was fired up to help make Watson's vision a reality.
他去过神学院。他经营过一个无家可归者事工。一旦你忽略了他的脏辫，AJ 看起来就像个很棒的二号人物。他热衷于帮助沃森将愿景变为现实。
I really believe strongly in submitting to African-American leadership, if you're in a largely minority setting-- or minority leadership, even. So I'm this white guy. So I say, yeah, man. I love the idea of, like-- I want to be in the inner city. I want to plant churches. Let me spend some time under you and just helping you do your thing.
我真的强烈认为，如果你在一个主要是少数族裔的环境中，应该顺服非裔美国人的领导——甚至是少数族裔的领导。所以我这个白人，我会说，是的，伙计。我喜欢这个想法，我想在市中心。我想建立教会。让我留在你手下，帮你做你的事。
Talked with my wife. We were like, yeah. I like it. Let's do it.
和我的妻子谈过了。我们觉得，是的。我喜欢它。我们干吧。
We prayed about it. And we felt like it was what the lord wanted.
我们为此祈祷。我们觉得这就是主想要的。
It was going to be called Restoration Church.
它将被命名为“复兴教会”（Restoration Church）。
Watson didn't have the direct connections to megachurches who might help fund Restoration. But he'd heard about some people who did-- a church planting network called Orchard Group. Orchard is this middleman organization. They help connect church plants to established churches that have a lot of money.
沃森没有直接联系到可能帮助资助复兴教会的大型教会。但他听说过一些有门路的人——一个叫“果园小组”（Orchard Group）的教会植堂网络。果园小组是中间人组织。他们帮助将教会植堂项目与资金雄厚的成熟教会联系起来。
Orchard Group is very selective. Of the thousands of people planting churches every year, about 100 apply with them, and the network only supports three or four. Watson called the president of the network directly. And before even putting in a formal application, they were excited about his vision.
果园小组非常有选择性。每年有成千上万的人建立教会，约有100人向他们申请，而该网络只支持三四个。沃森直接给该网络的负责人打了电话。在甚至还没有提交正式申请之前，他们就对他的愿景感到兴奋。
So in 2013, Restoration Church became one of the few churches they supported. They helped line up a good chunk of startup capital-- in total, about $100,000 per year for three years. Most of that was just going to cover his salary and half of AJ's. The reason for the three-year funding terms is that surveys of new churches show, if a church plant isn't sustainable after three years, it will likely never be sustainable. And nobody wants to sink their money into a failing church.
所以2013年，复兴教会成为他们支持的少数教会之一。他们帮助筹集了一大笔启动资金——总共约为每年10万美元，持续三年。其中大部分只是为了覆盖他的薪水和 AJ 的一半薪水。三年资助期限的原因是，对新教会的调查显示，如果一个教会植堂项目在三年后无法维持，它可能永远无法维持。没有人愿意把钱投入一个注定失败的教会。
And so, with their seed funding in place, the countdown started. It was April 2014, and Watson and AJ had three years to get this church off the ground, to attract enough people to become self-sustaining.
于是，随着种子资金到位，倒计时开始了。那是2014年4月，沃森和 AJ 有三年时间让这个教会起步，吸引足够多的人实现自负盈亏。
Initially, they just wanted people to come to a once-a-week Bible study at Watson's home. So the first thing they did was try to drum up interest the old-fashioned way-- through outreach on the streets in the neighborhood.
起初，他们只是想让人来沃森家参加每周一次的圣经学习。所以他们做的第一件事就是试图以老式的方式——通过在社区街道上进行外展活动——来激发兴趣。
Early on, man, me and AJ were out on corners, passing out coffee, free coffee, on bus stops.
早期，伙计，我和 AJ 在街角分发咖啡，免费咖啡，在公交车站。
We would make signs. We'd go to the community days. We'd go to volunteer at elementary schools.
我们会制作标志。我们会参加社区日活动。我们会去小学做志愿者。
We passed out water. We would have our team standing on crowded corners in the hot summer.
我们分发水。我们的团队会在炎热的夏天站在拥挤的街角。
We were handing out Blow Pops to people.
我们正在给人们分发 Blow Pops 棒棒糖。
This is Leah Smith, AJ's wife.
这是莉亚·史密斯（Leah Smith），AJ 的妻子。
And I think we put a little message on them-- let the love of God blow you away-- so corny. So corny. But we were trying to get people. It kind of felt like anything could happen at any moment.
我觉得我们在上面写了点信息——让神的爱让你震撼——太俗气了。太俗气了。但我们是在试图吸引人。感觉好像随时都可能发生任何事情。
So as we meet with people, we're going to ask, hey, man, who are three to four people you think would be interested in this? And we met a ton of people, a lot of people. We prayed for and prayed with a lot of people.
所以当我们和人们见面时，我们会问，嘿，伙计，你觉得有哪三到四个人会对这个感兴趣？我们见到了很多人，很多人。我们为很多人祈祷，也与很多人一起祈祷。
Over the course of just a few months, they had conversations with hundreds of people. And occasionally, some of them would take down Watson's address and show up to the Bible study.
在短短几个月的时间里，他们与数百人进行了交谈。偶尔，其中一些人会记下沃森的地址并出现在圣经学习中。
Any time a new person would come, it was like, ah, this is exciting! This is great!
任何时候有新人来，感觉就像，啊，这太令人兴奋了！这太棒了！
We had interest from all kinds of people-- people who didn't go to church, people who did go to church were very interested in us, because we looked different. And they liked us. They liked our spirit.
我们吸引了各种各样的人——不去教会的人，去教会的人对我们非常感兴趣，因为我们看起来不一样。他们喜欢我们。他们喜欢我们的精神。
For the most part, people were very receptive, and even, I'd say, very respectful of the ministry and what we were trying to do, and were very appreciative. But it didn't translate. We largely were not successful at getting people to come to our outreaches. It was a major disappointment.
在大多数情况下，人们非常接受，甚至可以说，非常尊重这个事工和我们试图做的事情，也非常感激。但它没有转化。我们在吸引人们参加外展活动方面基本是不成功的。这是一个重大的失望。
Man, I probably gained 20 pounds that year alone. It was extremely stressful.
伙计，那一年我可能胖了20磅。压力极大。
It felt like the outreaches were missing the mark. The goal had always been to reach people who weren't served by other churches, who weren't going to church. But by the end of six months, it was clear-- the people showing up, for the most part, were already church people coming from other churches. And they realized, maybe one of their basic premises was wrong. Something that other church plants always did, something that worked in the suburbs, was not working here.
感觉外展活动没有达到目标。目标一直是接触那些未被其他教会服务的、不去教会的人。但在六个月结束时，很清楚——出现的人在很大程度上已经是来自其他教会的教会人员。他们意识到，也许他们的一些基本前提是错误的。其他教会植堂项目总是做的、在郊区有效的事情，在这里行不通。
I think, in retrospect, what probably hurt us is, the thing to bring them to was a Bible study in my house. The first thing they'd ask me is, where is your church? Oh, well, we meet in my house.
我认为，回想起来，可能伤害我们的是，带他们来的地方是我家里的圣经学习班。他们问我的第一件事是，你的教会在哪里？噢，好吧，我们在我家聚会。
And one lady told me-- she said, you guys are a cult. You call me when you get a church. Especially, I think, among black people, the more out of the box or avant garde you are, the less likely you are to be trusted.
有一位女士告诉我——她说，你们是个邪教。等你们有了教堂再给我打电话。我认为，特别是在黑人中，你越是不按常理出牌或前卫，人们越不信任你。
Theologically, we say all day long, the church is the people of God. The people in your city, in your neighborhood, does not understand church apart from a building, a preacher, a choir or a praise team, and something that looks like a church service, period.
在神学上，我们整天说，教会就是神的子民。你所在的城市、你所在的社区里的人，如果不理解教会是离不开建筑物、传教士、唱诗班或赞美团队，以及看起来像教会礼拜的那种东西，周期性地（就是这样）。
That was really a gut check to us, because that was our-- that was plan A. And we weren't really sure what plan B was.
这对我们来说真是一个直觉测试，因为那是我们的——那是计划 A。我们真的不确定计划 B 是什么。
Plan A was the outreaches?
计划 A 是外展活动？
Yeah. I mean, we were going to be the people who were out there on the streets, pastors who were very much present with the people. And that's how we'll grow the church. That didn't work.
是的。我是说，我们要成为那些在街头上的人，牧师要与人们真正在一起。这就是我们将如何发展教会的方式。那行不通。
Hm. Why not?
嗯。为什么不行？
I think people have been to church. I think people have done church. And I think people don't have great experiences with church. And because of that, I think the last thing people want to do is waste a day, in their mind, of the weekend coming to church.
我认为人们去过教会。我认为人们做过教会。而且我认为人们在教会里并没有很好的经历。正因为如此，我认为人们最不想做的事情就是在他们的周末浪费一天时间来教会。
Yeah.
是啊。
I love what you all are doing, but you know-- OK, maybe I'll come by sometime. They ain't coming to church. They've been to church. Their uncle started a church 20 years ago, and they had to go sit through three hours on a Sunday morning, couldn't wait to get out of there. They couldn't wait till they were 18, and they didn't have to go to church anymore.
我喜欢你们所做的一切，但你知道——好吧，也许我以后会来看看。他们才不会来教会呢。他们去过教会。他们的叔叔20年前创办了一个教会，他们必须在周日上午坐在那里三个小时，迫不及待地想离开。他们等不及要等到18岁，这样他们就不必再去了。
This is perhaps where planting a church is most different from starting a company. It is very hard to get someone to try a new app. But what Watson was attempting seems even harder-- to get someone to try something they've already tried and rejected, and then to readjust their whole way of understanding the universe and their feelings about God, and to start going to church, and to help fund that church.
这也许就是植堂与创办公司最不同的地方。让某人尝试一个新的应用程序是非常困难的。但沃森所尝试的似乎更难——让某人尝试他们已经尝试过并拒绝的东西，然后重新调整他们看待宇宙的全部方式和对神的感受，并开始去教会，并帮助资助那个教会。
It's exactly the problem the church planting movement is supposed to solve, and does solve in lots of new churches. But the way most church planters usually solve this problem is to make church feel more relevant, meet in weirder spaces, like warehouses or coffee shops. There are church plants in breweries.
这正是教会植堂运动应该解决的问题，并且在许多新教会中确实解决了。但大多数植堂者通常解决这个问题的方法是让教会感觉更相关，在奇怪的空间里聚会，比如仓库或咖啡店。有些植堂项目在酿酒厂里。
The music in a typical church plant does not sound like the music in a traditional church. There are electric guitars with lots of effects on them. If they sing hymns, they're done in a style more like Mumford and Sons than Mozart.
典型的教会植堂项目中的音乐听起来不像传统教会中的音乐。有带有很多效果的电吉他。如果他们唱赞美诗，其风格更像是蒙福之子乐团（Mumford and Sons）而不是莫扎特。
[MUSIC - "I WILL WAIT" BY MUMFORD AND SONS]
[音乐 - 蒙福之子乐团的《I Will Wait》]
(SINGING) And I will--
(演唱) 我会——
This is a church plant worship service where they're literally just playing Mumford and Sons. And I got to say, the lyrics, "I will wait for you," land very differently when you're thinking about the rapture.
这是一个教会植堂崇拜仪式，他们实际上只是在播放蒙福之子乐团的音乐。我不得不说，当你想到被提（rapture）时，歌词“我会为你等待”的含义就完全不同了。
(SINGING) I will wait. I will wait for you. I will wait. I will wait--
(演唱) 我会等待。我会为你等待。我会等待。我会等待——
These churches are intentionally made to feel like going to a concert, not like going to church. There are professional lighting systems, and even smoke machines in some cases. But the thing about relevancy is that it's relative. A lot of that stuff-- the lights, the music-- it was designed by white people for white people.
这些教会故意让人感觉像去听音乐会，而不是去教会。有专业的照明系统，甚至在某些情况下还有烟雾机。但关于相关性的问题在于它是相对的。很多东西——灯光、音乐——都是白人设计的，为了白人。
What Watson and AJ were finding was that, in an African-American context in northwest Philly, those things don't necessarily feel relevant. So nine months in, Watson and AJ decided to scrap a key part of their business plan, one of the things that was going to make their church so different. And that's the part about having no building. They decided to reboot and to hold regular weekly services in a building, like the neighborhood seemed to want.
沃森和 AJ 发现的是，在费城西北部的非裔美国人语境中，这些东西不一定让人觉得相关。所以9个月后，沃森和 AJ 决定废除他们商业计划的关键部分，即那些使他们的教会如此与众不同的东西之一。那就是关于没有建筑物的部分。他们决定重启，并像社区似乎希望的那样，在一个建筑物里举行定期的每周礼拜。
They did two preview services-- preview services are a kind of beta test for the church-- in a banquet hall. They wanted to pick a space that didn't carry any of the negative connotations and baggage of a traditional church. But it was maybe a bit of an overcorrection.
他们做了两次预览礼拜——预览礼拜是教会的一种 Beta 测试——在宴会厅里。他们想选择一个不带有传统教会负面内涵和包袱的空间。但这可能有点矫枉过正。
We went to this place called Temptations. And we went to Temptations--
我们去了这个叫“诱惑”（Temptations）的地方。我们去了诱惑——
Wait, it's called Temptations?
等等，它叫“诱惑”？
Yeah, yeah, we-- yeah, we made all kind of jokes about that. Yeah, Temptations. The first time we went there, they just had trash everywhere-- hair weaves, and bras, and open bottles, and--
是的，是的，我们——是的，我们开了各种关于那个名字的玩笑。是的，诱惑。我们第一次去那里的时候，那里到处都是垃圾——发织、胸罩、开封的瓶子，还有——
Wait, there were literally, like, bras?
等等，那里真的有胸罩？
Yeah, yeah. We saw two bras, just on the floor, while trying to set our own stuff up.
是的，是的。我们就在那，试图布置我们自己的东西时，在地板上看到了两个胸罩。
So next, they tried an elementary school cafeteria. That's where they moved out of beta and held their first-ever regular Sunday service. In the church planting world, it's called launch Sunday. And it's a huge deal for a church plant-- a sort flag-on-the-moon moment saying, we are here to stay.
接下来，他们尝试了一个小学的食堂。那是他们结束 Beta 测试并举行第一次常规周日礼拜的地方。在教会植堂界，这被称为“启动周日”。这对教会植堂来说是一件大事——一种在月球上插旗的时刻，宣布我们已经扎根了。
It was March 2015, 11 months after they started, just about two years left on the countdown clock. They put out the word on Facebook, on flyers. They told family and friends. And then they prayed.
那是2015年3月，他们开始11个月后，倒计时钟上只剩下两年了。他们在 Facebook 上发布了消息，印了传单。他们告诉了家人和朋友。然后他们祈祷。
Were you nervous before?
你之前紧张吗？
Very, yeah. Very nervous, yes.
非常紧张，是的。非常紧张，是的。
What was going through your mind?
你当时在想什么？
What if no one comes? Why would they come? There was a guy I knew who had launched a church. And every week, it decreased until, like, a month later, it didn't exist anymore.
如果没人来怎么办？他们为什么要来？我认识一个创办过教会的家伙。每周都在减少，直到一个月后，它就不复存在了。
So in my mind, I'm like, well, what if that's me? What do I tell these donors who gave a lot of money to this? And what will I tell my wife? What will I tell my family? All of that.
所以在我的脑海里，我想，好吧，如果那是我呢？我该怎么告诉那些为这个捐了很多钱的捐赠者？我该怎么告诉我妻子？我该怎么告诉我的家人？所有这一切。
Amen. You may be seated in the presence of the lord.
阿门。在主的面前，请坐。
Watson woke up on the morning of March 22, 2015. He put on his brown corduroy pants, and a blue patterned shirt, and a white cardigan. And at 11:00 AM, he stepped up to the podium in front of more than 100 cafeteria chairs. And he started to pray.
2015年3月22日早晨，沃森醒来。他穿上棕色的灯芯绒裤子、一件蓝色图案衬衫和一件白色开衫。上午11点，他走上讲台，面对着100多把食堂椅子。他开始祈祷。
Lord, while we use technical terms of launching, and all of that stuff, Lord, we don't want any of all of this to stand in the way of you getting glory and you getting honor.
主啊，虽然我们使用“启动”之类的技术术语，所有这些，主啊，我们不希望所有这些阻碍你得到荣耀和尊荣。
What did the launch look like? How many people were there?
启动看起来是什么样子的？有多少人在场？
Man, I think it might have been maybe 150, maybe more.
伙计，我想可能有150人，甚至更多。
Wow.
哇。
Yeah.
是的。
That must have been huge. That must have felt really great.
那一定很棒。那一定感觉非常好。
It did. I cried, actually. And I'm not really a public crier. But I cried that day.
确实。我其实哭了。我不是一个喜欢在公共场合哭的人。但我那天哭了。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Why?
为什么？
Well, partly because I was surprised. When you have a launch, there's a gamble, man. And the deepest fear is, no one comes. And the fact that I walked in, and there were-- it was a lot of people there.
嗯，部分是因为我感到惊讶。当你有一个启动时，那是一个赌博，伙计。最深的恐惧是没人来。而我走进去，看到——那里有很多人。
I wanted to talk about this, because I need to define, why are we starting a church in a city of churches? You can drive down the street and you can see 10 of them on one block. There's a street not far from here where you can count five of them on one block.
我想谈谈这个，因为我需要定义，为什么我们要在一个教堂林立的城市里创办教会？你可以开车在街上走，你可以看到一个街区就有10个。离这儿不远有一条街，你可以在一个街区数出五个。
And it's simply to say this. You can't have too many, number one. But number two, we are being sent-- we, as the Church of Restoration, are being sent to represent the reconciler.
很简单就是这么说。第一，你不能有太多个。但第二，我们正被差遣——我们，作为复兴教会，正被差遣去代表那位和解者。
Amen. Can we give the Lord praise one more time for His word going forth this morning?
阿门。我们能为祂的话语今天上午传出再一次赞美主吗？
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
Amen.
阿门。
Yeah, we maxed out. We absolutely-- we had standing room in the-- it was standing room in the back. We completely maxed out. And it was like, OK this is great.
是的，我们爆满了。我们绝对——我们在后面有站立的空间——它是站立的空间。我们完全爆满了。当时感觉就是，OK，这太棒了。
So when I saw those people, I was like, OK, this is going to be like a regular church-type thing-- see you next week.
所以当我看到那些人时，我就想，OK，这就像一个普通的教会类型的事情——下周见。
Leah Smith again, AJ's wife.
莉亚·史密斯又开口了。
I wasn't thinking about it at that time, Eric. I wasn't thinking about church planting-- you kind of start small, and then you grow, and then you grow, and then you grow. I wasn't anticipating that, in the weeks to follow, the numbers would drop so harshly.
埃里克，我当时没那么想。我没在想教会植堂——你先从小做起，然后成长，成长，再成长。我没想到在随后的几周里，人数会下降得这么厉害。
The next week, only about 60 people showed up, fewer than half the launch. And then the next week was about the same, maybe even a little fewer. It turns out, a lot of the people who packed the church that first week were friends and family-- people already committed to other churches, but who came out once to show support. And so before long, Watson and AJ were back to the small group of about 30 or 40 people they had pulled in before moving into the building.
下周，只有大约60人出现，不到启动人数的一半。然后下一周也是差不多，甚至可能更少。原来，在第一周挤满教会的很多人是朋友和家人——那些已经承诺给其他教会，但出来露面一次以示支持的人。所以没过多久，沃森和 AJ 就回到了他们在搬进建筑物之前聚集的那30或40人的小组。
They were a year and a half into their three-year mission and they were stuck. So they tried new tactics, more direct forms of networking. They went door to door and prayed with people in the neighborhood. They tried getting members to invite their friends to church, rather than just strangers.
他们的三年使命已经过去了一年半，他们被困住了。所以他们尝试了新的策略，更直接的社交形式。他们挨家挨户去，并在社区里为人们祈祷。他们尝试让成员邀请他们的朋友来教会，而不是只邀请陌生人。
We would have invite cards. And we would say, listen, let's invite them to church on this day. We had them all on MailChimp. When we had big parties, like a Christmas party, we would email them out. And we would see who read them. Very few people would even open them.
我们会准备邀请卡。我们会说，听着，让我们邀请他们在这一天来教会。我们把他们都放在 MailChimp 里。当我们有大型聚会（比如圣诞晚会）时，我们会给他们发邮件。然后我们观察谁读了它们。很少有人甚至打开它们。
Some people would come, visit for a week, maybe two. But they wouldn't stay.
有些人会来，待上一周，也许两周。但他们不会留下来。
We had good follow-up. Like, we always-- me and AJ would hand-write cards to visitors. And there would be people who would comment, like, I love this church, all this other stuff. And they just never-- they would never come back.
我们有很好的后续跟进。就像我们总是——我和 AJ 会给访客手写卡片。会有一些人评论说，我喜欢这个教会，以及所有其他东西。但他们只是从未——他们再也没有回来过。
All these people would visit. Why wouldn't they stay?
这些人都会来访。为什么他们不留下来？
I don't know. I don't know.
我不知道。我不知道。
There were periods over the next year where attendance was so low, one person told me it felt like the band was playing for itself. The hardest stretches for Watson?
接下来的那一年里，有几段时间出席率如此之低，一个人告诉我，感觉乐队就像在为自己演奏。沃森最艰难的阶段？
Summer months. Summer months is when everybody in Philadelphia went to the shore, you know? Or everybody traveled. And so attendance-wise, man, it felt like someone took a scalpel and cut massive chunks off the church. Those periods were extremely deflating. I mean, they were dark moments.
夏季。夏天是费城每个人都去海边的时候，你知道吗？或者每个人都在旅行。所以出席率方面，伙计，感觉就像有人拿手术刀切掉了教会的一大块。那些阶段极其令人沮丧。我的意思是，那是非常黑暗的时刻。
Sometimes, I would battle depression. Most preachers tend to take Monday off, because you tend to be more prone to depression on a Monday, because Sunday, you expend so much of yourself, you know? You're preaching, and then you're talking to people. You're counseling people. You have meetings and all that other stuff.
有时，我会与抑郁作斗争。大多数传教士倾向于在周一休息，因为你在周一更容易倾向于抑郁，因为周日，你耗费了太多的自己，你知道吗？你在布道，然后你在和人交谈。你在辅导人。你有会议和所有其他的事情。
But for a church planter in an urban church struggling to move this thing, it was exponentially worse. You're tired. You're busy. You're lonely. You're burned out.
但对于一个在城市教会中努力推动这件事的植堂者来说，情况呈指数级恶化。你累了。你很忙。你很孤独。你精疲力竭。
I would wonder, was this God, or was this me? Did God really call me to Philly, or did he not? I felt like quitting, because any church planter I would ever talk to would say that they felt that at some point.
我曾想，这是神的意思，还是我自己的意思？神真的呼召我去费城了吗，还是没有？我觉得想放弃，因为我交谈过的任何教会植堂者都会说他们在某个时刻也有这种感觉。
Nearly two years went by like this. They'd get up to 60 people, and then they'd drop again. They were coming up on March 2017, their three-year deadline.
就这样过了近两年。他们会增加到60人，然后又下降。他们快要到2017年3月了，他们的三年最后期限。
It's not that you can't plant a church in a neighborhood like this and succeed. The church that Watson was a resident at, run by a pastor named Dr. Eric Mason-- it's nearly 12 years old now, with hundreds of attendees every week. Another preacher, named Doug Logan, has done something similar in Camden, New Jersey.
并不是说你不能在这样的社区里建立教会并成功。沃森曾驻点的那个教会，由埃里克·梅森（Dr. Eric Mason）博士经营——现在已经近12年了，每周有数百人参加。另一位叫道格·洛根（Doug Logan）的传教士在新泽西州的卡姆登也做了类似的事情。
But these guys, the Erics and the Dougs-- they are machines. They are not like normal people. They write books and organize conferences. They have web series. It's exactly the kind of mentality you imagine in a successful startup CEO. Watson was a talented guy with a lot of energy. But he wasn't that.
但这些家伙，埃里克和道格——他们是机器。他们不像普通人。他们写书，组织会议。他们有网络系列。这完全是你想象中一个成功的创业 CEO 的心态。沃森是个有才华、精力充沛的家伙。但他不是那样的人。
A lot of the times, I felt it was something about me. Maybe I'm doing something wrong. Maybe I'm missing something. This is not happening because you're just not a great leader, or you're not a great preacher, or you're not a great whatever, whatever, whatever. I don't know.
很多时候，我觉得这跟我自己有关。也许我做错了什么。也许我错过了一些什么。这之所以没有发生，是因为你不是一个伟大的领袖，或者你不是一个伟大的传教士，或者你不是一个伟大的什么什么什么。我不知道。
Yeah.
是啊。
I don't know.
我不知道。
On top of all this, Watson and his wife were dealing with all kinds of complicated family stuff.
除此之外，沃森和他的妻子还在处理各种复杂的家庭事务。
We had a miscarriage before my third child, and that was very painful. We had a diagnosis of autism on my first child. And in that same period, while starting a church, my wife almost died while giving birth to my final child. And all of that was a lot of trauma. I think it probably eventually made me wonder, is my time up?
在我的第三个孩子之前，我们流产了，那非常痛苦。我们的大孩子被诊断出患有自闭症。而在同一时期，在开始教会的同时，我的妻子在生我的最后一个孩子时差点死了。所有这一切都是巨大的创伤。我想这可能最终让我怀疑，我的时间到了吗？
Time was up. The three-year clock ran down. They still had some money coming in from their donors, and they were getting by. But Watson knew, some of those donors were going away. It wasn't going to be enough to pay both him and AJ. So last spring, Watson took a trip back home to Chicago, alone, to see his family.
时间到了。三年倒计时结束了。他们仍然从捐赠者那里得到一些钱，并且还能应付。但沃森知道，其中一些捐赠者要离开了。这不足以同时支付他和 AJ 的薪水。所以去年春天，沃森独自回到了芝加哥的家看望家人。
That weekend was Mother's Day weekend, actually. And I was on a layover in Chicago and I got to see my mother, right? And my mother-- it was the first time I had been with her on a Mother's Day for some years-- like, five years. It was so special. And I just started to feel like, man, if I could not go back, I wouldn't go back.
那个周末其实是母亲节周末。我在芝加哥中转，我见到了我的母亲，对吧？而我的母亲——这是我几年以来第一次在母亲节和她在一起——大约五年吧。那非常特别。我开始觉得，伙计，如果我能不回去，我就不会回去了。
I loved my church deeply. But I started to feel like the Lord was saying, it's time. So I talked to my wife about it. And I just said, look, I'm just going to tell you this. Don't get mad at me. But I'm just going to let you know exactly what I'm thinking here. And my wife said to me, you know, Watson, I've been feeling the same way.
我深深地爱着我的教会。但我开始觉得主在说，时候到了。所以我跟我妻子谈了这件事。我只是对她说，看，我只想告诉你这件事。别生我的气。我只想让你知道我在这里的想法。我妻子对我说，你知道，沃森，我也有同样的感觉。
And then, one Sunday morning last October, Watson got up in front of the congregation of Restoration. And he gave them a sermon that seemed like advice to prepare them for the road ahead.
然后，去年10月的一个周日上午，沃森站在复兴教会的会众面前。他发表了一篇布道，似乎是为他们的前路提供建议。
This is the part in your life where you cannot find your way. You don't know to go left. You don't know to go right. You don't know to go up. You don't know to go down.
这是你生活中无法找到出路的时刻。你不知道该往左走。你不知道该往右走。你不知道该往上走。你不知道该往下走。
You don't know who to call. You don't know where to go. This is the in-between times. And in-between times, according to the biblical narrative, have the ability to either make you, or they can break you.
你不知道给谁打电话。你不知道去哪里。这是中间的时光。而根据圣经叙事，中间的时光有能力要么成就你，要么摧毁你。
After the service, he had all the members stay for a meeting, at which point he said he was officially stepping down and they'd be going home to Chicago with his family. Taking over the church, AJ.
礼拜结束后，他让所有成员留下来开会，在会上他说他正式辞职了，他们将和家人回芝加哥。接管教会的是 AJ。
My first-- my first reaction was no-- like, no, no.
我的第一——我的第一反应是不——就像，不，不。
AJ's wife, Leah.
AJ 的妻子，莉亚。
No, you're not. I mean, majority African-American church. You're white.
不，你不是。我是说，以非裔美国人为主的教会。你是白人。
To be clear, Leah's mother is black. But her father is white and a pastor for majority-black congregations. But, she says, AJ is really, really white.
需要澄清的是，莉亚的母亲是黑人。但她的父亲是白人，是多数黑人会众的牧师。但是，她说，AJ 确实非常非常白。
AJ-- he's not submerged in black culture. He's just not. I mean, it just was just weird to me. And I felt a little bit self-conscious about it, and still do.
AJ——他没有沉浸在黑人文化中。他只是没有。我的意思是，这对我来说就是很奇怪。我对此感到有点拘束，现在仍然如此。
After moving back to Chicago, Watson looked around for another job. And he found himself drawn to exactly what he had been trying to disrupt-- an old church with a few hundred members and lots of years of baggage, Compassion Baptist Church. It was originally incorporated in 1879, two years after the end of Reconstruction.
搬回芝加哥后，沃森四处寻找另一份工作。他发现自己被他一直试图破坏的东西吸引了——一个拥有几百名成员、背负着多年历史包袱的旧教会，慈悲浸信会（Compassion Baptist Church）。它最初成立于1879年，重建结束后两年。
[APPLAUSE]
[掌声]
[CHEERING]
[欢呼]
This is a recording from the morning Watson was installed as the new pastor there. He's onstage in a suit. Turns out, the look really works for him. And behind him is the church's choir-- which, alone, is almost as large as Restoration was when Watson left.
这是沃森被任命为新牧师那天的录音。他穿着西装站在台上。事实证明，这个造型真的很适合他。在他身后是教会的唱诗班——仅此一项，就几乎和沃森离开时复兴教会的人数一样多。
At the church I'm at, for instance, the church is older than me. It's 138 years old. And my wife and I definitely brought the median age down some when we got there.
我在现在的教会，例如，教会比我老。它有138年的历史。我和我妻子到那里时，确实把中位年龄降下来了一些。
But it's been interesting to see the life in that church with me being there, the new, young guy. Younger people are starting to come or come back. So it shows me that you can be effective in an established church. But seven years ago, I didn't believe that. Seven or eight years ago, I didn't believe that at all.
但看到那个教会和我在一起生活的生命力，那个新的、年轻的家伙，非常有趣。年轻人开始来了，或者回来了。所以这向我证明，你可以在一个成熟的教会中发挥作用。但七年前，我不相信。七八年前，我根本不相信。
Some of those churches, man, survived the civil rights movement. Some of those churches brought black people in these cities through hellacious times. And then I, this little 26, 27, 28-year-old guy who just got a master's degree, wet behind the ears, I got the audacity to stand and critique something that's been around longer than me?
那些教会中的一些，伙计，在民权运动中幸存了下来。那些教会中的一些引领了这些城市中的黑人度过了地狱般的时期。然后我，这个刚拿到硕士学位的26、27、28岁的毛头小子，乳臭未干，我竟然有胆量站出来评判一个比我存在时间还长的东西？
Yeah.
是啊。
So my thoughts on that have changed.
所以我在那方面的想法改变了。
When Watson looks back at what went wrong at Restoration, there's a mix of things he comes back to. Partly, he thinks, it was him. He was a guy from Chicago trying to reach native Philadelphians. He had a big personality, but the planting process drained a lot of that out of him.
当沃森回顾复兴教会哪里出了问题时，他回想起了一些事情。部分原因，他认为，是他自己。他是一个来自芝加哥的家伙，试图接触费城的当地人。他有很大的个性，但植堂的过程抽干了其中的很多东西。
But the real problem was probably their original premise-- to buck the conventional wisdom and locate in a neighborhood that wasn't gentrifying. People were already settled, stable. Now, Watson realizes just how much harder that made things. His intention was pure, but he didn't understand the difficulty of what he was setting out to do.
但真正的问题可能是他们最初的前提——试图对抗传统智慧，选址在没有士绅化的社区。人们已经安顿下来，很稳定。现在，沃森意识到他让事情变得有多难。他的意图是纯洁的，但他不明白他着手要做的事情的难度。
If you want something to grow and be self-sustaining, this was not the place to do it. And the rest of the church gets that now. After Watson left, Restoration moved into a new neighborhood, one more in transition. And they bought a building. They're learning from their mistakes-- or anyway, they hope they are.
如果你想让某事成长并实现自负盈亏，这不是做这件事的地方。教会的其他人现在明白了。沃森离开后，复兴教会搬到了一个新的社区，一个更处于转型中的社区。他们买了一座建筑物。他们正在从错误中学习——或者无论如何，他们希望他们是。
Eric Mennel-- he tells the story of what happens after AJ takes over the church and moves it to a different area. That is the new season of the podcast StartUp. You can find StartUp at Apple Podcasts or gimletmedia.com, or wherever it is that you get your podcasts.
埃里克·门内尔——他讲述了 AJ 接管教会并将其搬到不同地区后发生的故事。这是播客《StartUp》的新一季。你可以在 Apple Podcasts 或 gimletmedia.com，或者任何你获取播客的地方找到《StartUp》。
[MUSIC - "I'M WORKING ON THE BUILDING" BY B.B. KING]
[音乐 - B.B. King 的《I'm Working On The Building》]
Coming up, another newcomer arrives into a neighborhood. But instead of trying to get people to pray, her goal was simpler. She just wants them to drink. But attracting sinners can be just as tricky as attracting saints. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，另一位新来者抵达了一个社区。但她的目标不是试图让人祈祷，她的目标更简单。她只是想让他们喝酒。但吸引罪人可能和吸引圣徒一样棘手。从芝加哥公共广播电台，我们的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme and bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, If You Build It, Will They Come? Stories of people working and trying their hardest to create something, making mistakes they never thought could be mistakes. We've arrived at Act Two of our program-- Act Two, Hole in the Wall.
这是《This American Life》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。每周在我们的节目中，当然，我们选择一个主题，并为您带来关于该主题的不同种类的故事。今天的节目，如果你盖好了，他们会来吗？人们努力工作并竭尽全力创造事物的故事，犯下他们从未想过可能是错误的错误。我们已经到了节目的第二幕——第二幕，墙上的洞。
So one of our coworkers here at the radio show, Neil Drumming, enjoys a drink now and then. And since he moved into his neighborhood a few years ago, he has visited just about every bar there, except one. He has stayed away. He'll explain why.
我们电台的同事之一，尼尔·德拉明（Neil Drumming），偶尔喜欢喝一杯。自从几年前他搬进社区以来，他已经参观了那里几乎所有的酒吧，只有一个除外。他避而远之。他会解释原因。
And just a quick heads up here in the podcast that this story has some people in it who do not go to church, and we have un-beeped their ungodly cursing here in the podcast version of the show. If you want a beeped version-- maybe you're listening with kids, maybe you were interviewed in the first half of the program-- that version is at our website. Here's Neil.
播客里提个醒，这个故事里有一些人不去教会，我们在播客版本的节目中没有把他们不敬神的诅咒消音。如果你想要消音版本——也许你在和孩子一起听，也许你是节目前半部分被采访的人——那个版本在我们网站上。这是尼尔。
Last year, this restaurant in my neighborhood got into a lot of trouble with the locals. Summerhill, the restaurant, sits at the northeast corner of St. Marks and Nostrand Avenue in Crown Heights, a rapidly gentrifying area in Brooklyn. Basically, what happened was, in July of 2017, just after Summerhill opened to the public, the restaurant's owner, a white woman from Canada named Becca Brennan, put out a press release touting a few of her new venture's more unique characteristics-- surf club vibe, massive accordion window, and then, oddly, a quote, "bullet hole-ridden wall."
去年，我社区的这家餐馆给当地人惹了很大的麻烦。Summerhill 这家餐馆位于皇冠高地（Crown Heights）圣马可和诺斯特兰大道的东北角，这是一个正在迅速士绅化的布鲁克林地区。基本上发生的事情是，2017年7月，Summerhill 对公众开放后，餐馆的所有者，一位名叫贝卡·布伦南（Becca Brennan）的加拿大白人女性，发布了一份新闻稿，大肆宣扬她这一新创意的几个独特特征——冲浪俱乐部氛围、巨大的手风琴窗，然后，奇怪的是，还有一句引语：“布满弹孔的墙壁。”
The release stated, yes, that bullet hole-ridden wall was originally there. And yes, we're keeping it. In an interview with the website Gothamist, Brennan suggested that this interior wall, speckled with paint and cracked plaster, was left over from a rumored back-room illegal gun shop. Brennan also told the reporter that Summerhill would be serving something called 40-ounce wine in paper bags.
发布声明称，是的，那面布满弹孔的墙原来就在那里。是的，我们保留它。在接受 Gothamist 网站采访时，布伦南暗示这面布满油漆和裂开石膏的内墙，是从一个传说中的非法枪支店后室留下的。布伦南还告诉记者，Summerhill 将提供一种叫“40盎司葡萄酒”的东西，放在纸袋里。
This kind of thing happens so much in gentrifying Brooklyn that it's hardly notable anymore. Some trendy eatery, bar, or boutique flower shop will open where there used to be an old record store or a Caribbean takeout joint. And the owners will keep the crumbling facade, a faded sign, or a rusty light fixture visible, as if to say, hey, we love what used to be here. We're not here to change the neighborhood. We just want to be a part of it.
这种事情在正在士绅化的布鲁克林发生得太多了，以至于几乎不再引人注目。一些时髦的餐馆、酒吧或精品花店会开在曾经是旧唱片店或加勒比外卖店的地方。业主会保留破碎的门面、褪色的标志或生锈的灯具，仿佛在说，嘿，我们喜欢这里曾经的样子。我们不是来改变社区的。我们只是想成为其中的一部分。
But in this case, Becca Brennan was indulging a bit of dark urban fantasy. The holes in the wall in question were not bullet holes, but actually anchor points for one of those big commercial refrigerators you find in any bodega. Summerhill had been completely remodeled from an old corner store that had once stood in that location.
但在这种情况下，贝卡·布伦南是在沉溺于一种黑暗的城市幻想。那面墙上的洞不是弹孔，而是你在任何便利店（bodega）都能找到的那种大商业冰箱的锚点。Summerhill 是从曾经位于那个位置的一家旧街角商店彻底改造而来的。
Gothamist immediately ran a story about Summerhill's launch that included the interview with Brennan and a quote from a member of the Crown Heights Tenants Union accusing her of profiting from the neighborhood's unfortunate history of violence. TV news outlets and other websites, like Eater, picked up the story. And the next thing you know--
Gothamist 立即发表了一篇关于 Summerhill 开业的故事，包括对布伦南的采访，以及皇冠高地租户联盟成员的一句引语，指责她利用社区不幸的暴力历史牟利。电视新闻媒体和其他网站，如 Eater，报道了这个故事。接下来的事你知道——
You ain't gonna take some motherfucking pain!
你不会拿走一些他妈的痛苦！
--there was an angry mob standing outside Summerhill, protesting.
——有一个愤怒的暴徒站在 Summerhill 外面，抗议。
You not gonna take our pain and make it a novelty!
你不会拿走我们的痛苦并把它变成新奇的东西！
She said, "You're not going to take our pain and make it a novelty." This is from a video shot by Gothamist in July of last year. There were a lot of different kinds of people in the crowd outside of Summerhill, mostly young, presumably new to the neighborhood, certainly not all black. But the woman standing on the chair, yelling, is black. And when she shouts, "You're not going to take our pain and make it a novelty," she's talking about the pain of a predominantly African-American community that has long struggled with gun violence.
她说，“你不会拿走我们的痛苦并把它变成新奇的东西。”这是去年7月由 Gothamist 拍摄的一段视频。Summerhill 外面人群中有许多不同类型的人，大多是年轻人，想必是社区的新人，当然并非全是黑人。但站在椅子上大喊的那个女人是黑人。当她喊“你不会拿走我们的痛苦并把它变成新奇的东西”时，她谈论的是一个长期与枪支暴力斗争的非裔美国人社区的痛苦。
I'd been living in Crown Heights less than a couple of years when this all went down. But when I moved here, one of the things I noticed were the signs-- the actual signs posted in storefronts near my apartment counting the days since the last shooting incident. Becca Brennan had chosen to make light of an issue that many people in the area took very seriously. And when a community meeting was called a month later to discuss it, what she said to the group just made things worse. She downplayed how much she'd talked about the bullet holes.
当这一切发生时，我在皇冠高地住了不到几年。但当我搬到这里时，我注意到的事情之一是标志——实际张贴在商店橱窗里、靠近我的公寓的标志，数着距离上次枪击事件过去的天数。贝卡·布伦南选择轻描淡写一个许多地区人民非常严肃对待的问题。而当一个月后召开社区会议讨论此事时，她对小组所说的话只会让事情变得更糟。她淡化了她谈论弹孔的次数。
People would come in and say, are you keeping that wall? And I was-- I said yes. And some people would say, are those bullet holes? And I never once, to a person, said, yes, those are bullet holes. They are obviously holes from anchors in the wall. That's where the soda fridge was when the bodega was up, OK? So I'm sorry I have a sense of humor and--
人们进来问，你要保留那面墙吗？我当时是——我说是的。有些人会说，那是弹孔吗？我从来没有对任何一个人说过，是的，那是弹孔。它们显然是墙上的锚留下的洞。那就是以前那家便利店有汽水冰箱的地方，OK？所以我很抱歉我有幽默感和——
That meeting got pretty heated. Brennan remained defensive and defiant as locals and their elected officials challenged her to apologize for her insensitivity. Some predicted that, without her contrition, Summerhill would soon shut down. Here's audio from another protest outside the restaurant, calling for just that.
那次会议非常激烈。布伦南保持防御和挑衅，当地人和他们的民选官员挑战她为她的麻木不仁道歉。一些人预测，如果没有她的忏悔，Summerhill 很快就会倒闭。这是餐馆外另一次抗议的录音，呼吁正是如此。
Bye-bye, Becky. Bye-bye, Becky. Bye-bye, Becky.
再见，贝基。再见，贝基。再见，贝基。
Becca Brennan didn't want to talk to us for this story. When Summerhill first opened, I had thought about stopping in for a drink a couple of times. But after I heard about the protest and skimmed the articles, staying clear felt like a no-brainer.
贝卡·布伦南不想为这个故事接受我们的采访。Summerhill 刚开业时，我曾想过进去喝一杯。但在听到抗议并浏览了文章后，远离它感觉是理所当然的。
This conflict had two distinct sides. And even though I was pretty new to the neighborhood myself, there was no way I was going to align with the 31-year-old white gentrifier who fabricates a memorial to violence out of distressed concrete and an unconventional sense of humor. No question, I would stand with my people-- which, in a practical sense, just meant going instead to the bar across the street or the one around the corner.
这种冲突有两个明显的方面。即使我也是社区的新人，我也不可能与那个31岁的白人士绅化者站在一边，她用痛苦的混凝土和非传统的幽默感制造了一个针对暴力的纪念碑。毫无疑问，我会和我们自己人站在一起——这实际上意味着去街对面的酒吧或拐角处的酒吧。
I didn't think about Summerhill for months. And then, less than a year later, it was 10 or 11 o'clock on a weekend, and I walked past the place. It was packed. The restaurant sits at an intersection and customers were spilling out onto the corner-- the same corner that had been overwhelmed with pissed-off protesters just last summer.
我有几个月没想过 Summerhill 了。然后，不到一年后，周末晚上10点或11点，我走过了那个地方。它挤满了人。餐馆位于十字路口，顾客溢到了拐角处——那个去年夏天被愤怒的抗议者淹没的同一个拐角处。
Now, though, people inside and out seemed happy. They were drinking, partying, and it was really loud. I remember, because the DJ was playing something from Camp Lo's 1997 cult classic, Uptown Saturday Night. I love that album.
不过现在，里面和外面的人看起来都很开心。他们正在喝酒、聚会，声音非常大。我记得，因为 DJ 在播放 Camp Lo 1997年的邪典经典《Uptown Saturday Night》。我喜欢那张专辑。
Oh, yeah, and pretty much everybody in the place was black. I felt like I'd missed the memo. Like, who ordered us to stand down? Not that I'd ever really stood up, but a lot of people had. I was at a bar across the street from Summerhill when I met a really friendly guy named Tashaka, who'd also been avoiding the crowds at Summerhill.
哦，是的，地方里几乎每个人都是黑人。我觉得我错过了备忘录。就像，谁命令我们退缩的？不是说我真的站出来过，但很多人都站出来过。我在 Summerhill 街对面的酒吧时，遇到了一个名叫塔沙卡（Tashaka）的非常友好的家伙，他也一直避开 Summerhill 的人群。
But the reason I don't go in is because, initially, it was because she was-- they were being-- she was being boycotted and I didn't want to cross the line.
但我没进去的原因是，最初是因为她——他们正在——她正在被抵制，我不想跨越界限。
So you didn't actually protest?
所以你其实没有抗议？
Hm?
嗯？
You didn't actually protest?
你其实没有抗议？
Did I actually protest? Mm, I won't say-- I didn't-- I didn't stand outside.
我抗议了吗？嗯，我不会说——我没有——我没有站在外面。
Yeah, me neither.
是啊，我也没。
So why do you think that people started going after all? Why did black people decide--
所以你觉得为什么人们最后开始去了？为什么黑人决定——
Because--
因为——
--to start going?
——开始去？
--we're very forgiving.
——我们非常宽容。
Say it again?
再说一遍？
We're very forgiving. It's like, you can smack us in the face, and if you say you're sorry and you're not going to do it again, we'll usually accept you. You know it's true. You're smiling, and you're giggling, but you know it's true.
我们非常宽容。就像，你可以扇我们脸，如果你说对不起，并且以后不再这样做，我们通常会接受你。你知道这是真的。你微笑着，你在傻笑，但你知道这是真的。
For the record, I don't think I was giggling. Look, I take Tashaka's point. To put it lightly, African-Americans have been very forgiving about a lot of things over the years. But that wasn't a very satisfying answer. I just kind of wanted to know what really happened. So I walked across the street.
郑重声明，我不觉得我在傻笑。听着，我接受塔沙卡的观点。说得轻一点，多年来，非裔美国人在很多事情上一直非常宽容。但这并不是一个非常令人满意的答案。我只是想知道到底发生了什么。所以我走过了马路。
And what made you come here?
是什么让你来到这儿？
We were walking down Nostrand, and we were just trying to find somewhere to have a quick drink. And we just stumbled upon this place and decided to try it.
我们在诺斯特兰大道上走，我们只是想找个地方快速喝一杯。我们就碰巧来到这个地方，决定试一试。
What are you guys drinking?
你们在喝什么？
Oh, rum punch.
哦，朗姆潘趣酒。
Rum punch.
朗姆潘趣酒。
[LAUGHING]
[笑]
Some folks hadn't heard anything about the drama from last year.
有些人还没听说过去年发生的戏剧性事件。
You know, I don't even-- I didn't even know that. I think I'm-- yeah, I didn't know that.
你知道，我甚至——我甚至不知道那个。我想我是——是的，我不知道。
Some people, like Tara here, had heard about the wall and the alleged bullet holes, and definitely felt some kind of way about it.
有些人，比如这里的塔拉（Tara），听说过那面墙和所谓的弹孔，确实对此有某种感觉。
And to put it on display and not be a person of color, and not have been a person who experienced that day in, day out, that's not your story to tell. That's our story to tell.
并把它展示出来，而却不是有色人种，也没有经历过那一天，那不是你的故事。那是我们的故事。
But the wall's been plastered over. Work from a local artist hangs there now. From Tara's point of view, the slate has been adequately wiped clean. She's there all the time now.
但墙被抹平了。当地艺术家的作品现在挂在那里。从塔拉的观点来看，这页已经相当充分地翻过去了。她现在一直都在那里。
Yeah, I feel like things deliberately changed here. I think there's definitely a different vibe here. I think there's a different culture provided here than that was provided beforehand.
是的，我觉得这里的事情确实改变了。我觉得这里肯定有一种不同的氛围。我觉得这里提供的文化与之前提供的不同。
This is Neil-- another black Neil in Brooklyn. Who knew?
这是尼尔——布鲁克林另一个黑人尼尔。谁知道呢？
Like, I'll post on Snapchat and I'll have the Summerhill geotag. And somebody will be like, oh, you go to that racist bar? That has happened before on my Snapchat.
比如，我会发布在 Snapchat 上，我会加上 Summerhill 的地理标记。有人会说，哦，你去那个种族主义酒吧了？在我的 Snapchat 上发生过这种情况。
He's here nevertheless, undaunted-- in fact, twice in two nights. And the reason he keeps coming back?
尽管如此，他还是来了，毫不畏惧——实际上两晚来了两次。而他不断回来的原因？
Oyo, who is now part owner-- I knew him from working at another bar. So I knew that he was working here, or had become an owner here. So I decided to come here to support him.
奥约（Oyo），现在是合伙所有人——我从在另一家酒吧工作时就认识他。所以我知道他在为这里工作，或者已经成为这里的所有人。所以我决定来这里支持他。
And like that, I had my answer. I heard this from people inside and out of Summerhill-- staff and bartenders at other bars, regulars and haters. If you want to know why so many people come to Summerhill, look for Oyo.
就这样，我得到了答案。我从 Summerhill 的内内外外都听到了这一点——员工和酒吧招待，常客和喷子。如果你想知道为什么这么多人来 Summerhill，找奥约。
Wallahi Oyo-- he mostly goes by just Oyo-- is the executive chef at Summerhill. He became partial owner of the restaurant shortly after all the controversy began. He comes up with the menu. He picks the DJs. On a busy Saturday night, you might find him standing out front, scanning Nostrand Avenue from beneath a black baseball cap, presumably looking for more customers. The word was, the embattled Becca Brennan took a diminished role in her own business so that a 27-year-old black man could become the face of Summerhill.
瓦拉奥约（Wallahi Oyo）——他通常只叫奥约——是 Summerhill 的行政主厨。在争议开始后不久，他成为了餐馆的部分所有人。他负责菜单。他选择 DJ。在一个忙碌的周六晚上，你可能会发现他站在前面，在黑色棒球帽下扫描诺斯特兰大道，推测是在寻找更多顾客。消息是，陷入困境的贝卡·布伦南在自己的业务中担任了削减的角色，以便一名27岁的黑人男子能够成为 Summerhill 的门面。
It's not like she has no involvement. There's a lot of stuff that she still does. But I feel like, mostly, when people come here, they see Oyo.
并不是说她没有参与。她仍然做了很多事情。但我觉得，大多数时候，人们来这里时，他们看到的是奥约。
Oyo's wasn't just a symbolic contribution. I spoke to him in the kitchen that he oversees. If you ask him what exactly he and Becca did to get black people to come Summerhill after the protests and the bad press, he'll tell you nothing. He and his partner just weathered the storm, and eventually, people came. But that's not exactly true. Faced with the storm, Oyo sent up flares.
奥约的不仅仅是象征性的贡献。我和他谈到了他监督的厨房。如果你问他和贝卡到底做了什么，在抗议和负面新闻之后，让黑人来到 Summerhill，他会告诉你什么都没做。他和他的合伙人只是挺过了风暴，最终，人们来了。但这并不完全正确。面对风暴，奥约发出了信号。
And I said-- I told my friends, yo, come on. I need help. My bar has been protested. I need help. I mean, I need-- you know what I'm saying? I need y'all to come support, because I'm drowning.
我说——我告诉我的朋友，哟，过来。我需要帮助。我的酒吧被抗议了。我需要帮助。我的意思是，我需要——你知道我在说什么吗？我需要你们来支持，因为我快淹死了。
And from the look of things, many of them did come. Maybe you've heard, we're a forgiving people. But not all of us.
从情况来看，他们中的许多人确实来了。也许你听说过，我们是一个宽容的民族。但并不是我们所有人。
She's using his blackness, in a way, to build this business and make it cool again, because of her mistake.
她利用他的黑人身份，在某种程度上，来建立这个业务并让它再次变得很酷，因为她的错误。
This is Justine Stephens. She and two of her peers organized the first protests against Summerhill after reading about the place on Gothamist last year. She still refuses to step foot inside. But she has noticed Summerhill becoming increasingly popular with black folks in the last few months. She says that's all Oyo remaking the place's image.
这是贾斯汀·斯蒂芬斯（Justine Stephens）。去年在 Gothamist 上阅读了关于这个地方的消息后，她和她的两个同行组织了对 Summerhill 的首次抗议。她仍然拒绝踏进里面一步。但她注意到 Summerhill 在过去几个月里在黑人群体中越来越受欢迎。她说这一切都是奥约重塑了这个地方的形象。
A lot of their online press is kind of fashioned in a way where it's-- it looks hip. It looks like a club scene. Like, if I take out my phone now and take a look at it-- like Wednesday Night Jump Up, for example. I don't think Caucasian Becca Brennan from Toronto would say "jump up."
他们的很多在线新闻都是以某种方式设计的——它看起来很潮。看起来像个俱乐部场景。比如，如果我现在拿出手机看一眼——比如周三晚上的 Jump Up。我不觉得多伦多的高加索人贝卡·布伦南会说“jump up”。
I mean, wouldn't that be something that is more representative-- that kind of marketing, that kind of branding-- more representative of the community?
我的意思是，那难道不是更具代表性的吗——那种营销，那种品牌塑造——更代表社区？
But is it pandering?
但这是迎合吗？
I don't know. Is it? I mean, if-- it's kind of like, if they advertise for something, they advertise something that people in the community want, or cleave to, or are excited by, and those people come, and they support it, is that pander--
我不知道。是吗？我的意思是，如果——这有点像，如果他们为某事做广告，他们广告的是社区里人们想要的、坚持的或感到兴奋的东西，而那些人来了，他们支持它，那是迎合——
No, I think that's totally fair. I think, if it was any other bar that he decided to open up or join forces with, I think that's fair. But again, the profits are not fully going to him. And he's doing her a big-ass favor by making grits and playing Beyonce.
不，我觉得那是完全公平的。我觉得，如果那是他决定开设或加入的任何其他酒吧，我觉得那是公平的。但再次，利润并没有完全流向他。他在为她帮了一个大忙，做粗粮并播放碧昂丝（Beyonce）的音乐。
On Instagram, Justine accused Oyo of helping Becca Brennan get the quote unquote, "black dollar." And this annoyed the hell out of Oyo.
在 Instagram 上，贾斯汀指责奥约帮助贝卡·布伦南赚取所谓的“黑人美元”。这让奥约非常恼火。
I'm doing this for my pockets, you know what I'm saying? This is my business. Don't think that I'm doing this for her.
我做这个是为了我的口袋，你知道我在说什么吗？这是我的生意。别以为我在为她做这个。
I don't think she's using me. If anything, I'm using Becca, you know what I'm saying? Like, trust me. This is for my pockets.
我不觉得她在利用我。如果有的话，我在利用贝卡，你知道我在说什么吗？比如，相信我。这是为了我的口袋。
Oyo thinks about his pockets a lot. An unapologetic capitalist, Oyo learned from his dad, who owned a nail salon nearby. Later, Oyo himself ran a DVD shop on the block, and then he worked as a chef at a black-owned bar down the street. He said that he loves doing business in Crown Heights, and that people in the neighborhood have been waiting for him to open up his own spot.
奥约想了很多关于他口袋的事。作为一个毫无歉意的资本主义者，奥约从他爸爸那里学到了，他爸爸在附近拥有一家美甲店。后来，奥约自己在街区经营一家 DVD 商店，然后他在街对面的一个黑人拥有的酒吧当厨师。他说他喜欢在皇冠高地做生意，社区里的人一直在等他开设自己的店。
Before the protests happened, Oyo convinced Becca Brennan to let him launch a pop-up sandwich shop inside her fledgling restaurant. They were both satisfied with how that went, so they started negotiating for Oyo to accept an ownership stake in the restaurant.
抗议发生之前，奥约说服了贝卡·布伦南让他启动一个餐馆内的快闪三明治店。他们对结果都很满意，所以他们开始协商奥约接受餐馆的所有权股份。
Then came Justine and the protesters. Oyo took the deal anyway. It was the open door that he'd been waiting for, and there was no way he wasn't going to walk through it, no matter how many people stood outside, jeering. He became partners with Becca.
然后是贾斯汀和抗议者。奥约还是接下了这个交易。那是他一直在等待的一扇敞开的门，无论外面有多少人在嘲笑，他都不可能不走进去。他成了贝卡的合伙人。
Were you worried?
你担心吗？
No. My confidence in myself was, no, I'm not worried. Me, you know, I feel like I'm Oyo. I can make it happen.
不。我对自己的信心是，不，我不担心。我，你知道，我觉得我是奥约。我可以让它发生。
Even Oyo will admit that Becca Brennan made a mistake. And for most people, that was the story-- a white woman who offended some people in a historically black neighborhood. But it's this other, smaller interaction that gets to me more-- two black people, Justine and Oyo, pointing at each other, asking who really belongs here.
即使是奥约也会承认贝卡·布伦南犯了一个错误。对于大多数人来说，那是故事——一个在历史悠久的黑人社区冒犯了一些人的白人女性。但正是这个其他、较小的互动更让我触动——两个黑人，贾斯汀和奥约，互相指着对方，询问谁真正属于这里。
When Justine saw Oyo defending his mostly silent white partner, she saw a black man who was willing to sell out his community for bread crumbs. Justine was new to the area, but her father grew up in Brooklyn. She thought that the people in the neighborhood deserved better and that she needed to alert them. Oyo was, in her mind, a puppet.
当贾斯汀看到奥约为他大多沉默的白人合伙人辩护时，她看到了一个黑人男子，他愿意为了面包屑出卖他的社区。贾斯汀对这个地区来说是个新人，但她的父亲在布鲁克林长大。她认为社区里的人值得更好的，她需要提醒他们。奥约，在她的心目中，是一个傀儡。
But when Oyo looked out and saw Justine leading a crowd of mostly white protesters, he didn't see a representative of the community. He was from the community. He had a tattoo on his arm of the street sign at Bedford and St. Marks, right up the block. Justine, who was from Norwalk, Connecticut, had chemically straightened hair, and she was threatening his pockets.
但当奥约向外看并看到贾斯汀领导着一大群主要是白人的抗议者时，他并没有看到社区的代表。他来自这个社区。他在手臂上有一个贝德福德和圣马可的街名标志纹身，就在街区上方。来自康涅狄格州诺沃克（Norwalk）的贾斯汀，留着化学拉直的头发，她正在威胁他的口袋。
I had braids. I'm not trying to look like no fucking white bitch, I'm telling you. I'm telling you--
我有辫子。我没想看起来像个他妈的白人婊子，我告诉你。我告诉你——
Justine sent me this recording from that day. It's noisy, but if you tune out the strands of Whitney Houston emanating from inside Summerhill, you can hear a screaming match erupt between Justine and Oyo.
贾斯汀那天给我发了这个录音。它很吵，但如果你屏蔽掉从 Summerhill 内部传出的惠特尼·休斯顿（Whitney Houston）的声音，你可以听到贾斯汀和奥约之间爆发的尖叫对峙。
Get the fuck out of there.
滚出去。
You grow up black and you straighten your hair?
你长大是黑人，然后你拉直你的头发？
Oyo goes low almost immediately, attacking Justine for relaxing her hair texture to look like a white woman's while fighting for a so-called black cause. When Justine says that's what black women do, Oyo replies, "Stupid black women." In the days following this eruption, Justine received even more hateful and disturbing messages via Facebook.
奥约几乎立即开始攻击贾斯汀，攻击她为了看起来像个白人女性而放松发质，同时为所谓的黑人事业而战。当贾斯汀说这就是黑人女性所做的时，奥约回答说，“愚蠢的黑人女性。”在这个爆发后的几天里，贾斯汀通过 Facebook 收到了更多令人憎恶和不安的信息。
Can I say all the words?
我能把所有词都说出来吗？
Sure.
当然。
OK. "Go kill yourself, bitch. You're a fucking black bitch who wants to be white, but out here protesting about Black Lives Matter. You got nothing to do. Claim you're so pro-black, but have mad white people protesting with you, like they really give a fuck about you. You're really--"
OK。“去自杀吧，婊子。你是一个他妈的想成为白人的黑人婊子，但在这里抗议黑人的命也是命（Black Lives Matter）。你没事可做。声称你非常支持黑人，但让疯狂的白人跟着你抗议，就像他们真的在乎你一样。你真的——”
The Facebook messages went on and on. They were anonymous, but because the insults were similar to things he'd said to her face, Justine thinks Oyo was responsible. I asked him about it. He doesn't deny that the comments could have come from some of his associates trying to support him in the worst way imaginable, but he insists that it wasn't him.
Facebook 信息没完没了。它们是匿名的，但因为侮辱与他当面对她说的相似，贾斯汀认为奥约负有责任。我问他了。他不否认这些评论可能来自他的一些试图以最糟糕的方式支持他的同伙，但他坚持那不是他。
Oyo told me that he mocked Justine's hair because he was raised in a home where relaxers and weaves weren't allowed, where keeping your hair natural was a sign of how pro-black you were. But then, it was Oyo's mother who ultimately told them to apologize to Justine, because he shouldn't talk to black women like that. He did try. Justine showed me contrite messages he'd sent to her on Instagram. But she's no longer interested in opening a dialogue with Oyo or anyone involved with Summerhill.
奥约告诉我，他嘲笑贾斯汀的头发是因为他在一个不允许松弛剂和发织的家庭中长大，在那里，保持你的头发自然是你多么支持黑人的标志。但后来，最终是奥约的母亲让他们向贾斯汀道歉，因为他不应该那样对待黑人女性。他确实试过了。贾斯汀向我展示了他在 Instagram 上发给她的悔悟信息。但她不再有兴趣与奥约或任何与 Summerhill 有关的人进行对话。
So what would it take for you to visit that bar?
所以你需要什么才会访问那家酒吧？
I'm not going to. I'm actually afraid to go in there, because I'm not going to-- again, I don't want to risk my safety.
我不会去。实际上我很怕进去，因为我不会——再次，我不想冒我的安全风险。
Have you walked past it?
你走过它吗？
I walk past it every day.
我每天走过它。
I have to say, it really bothered me to hear about this seemingly unbridgeable chasm between Justine and Oyo. And not just because Justine shouldn't have to fear for her safety in her own neighborhood, and not just because the debate they're essentially having over who is a bigger sellout and who is more authentically black is an ugly, unwinnable contest and more than a little absurd.
我不得不说，听到关于贾斯汀和奥约之间这种看似无法弥合的鸿沟，这真让我感到困扰。不仅仅是因为贾斯汀不应该在自己的社区里害怕自己的安全，也不仅仅是因为他们本质上在争论谁是更大的出卖者，谁更真实地是黑人，这是一个丑陋的、无法赢的竞争，而且有点荒谬。
But mostly, it upsets me simply because she's 26 and he's 27. They're both young and black, with roots in Brooklyn. She likes soca. His bar blasts soca music well into the night. It just doesn't seem like they should be so far apart.
但最主要的是，这让我心烦意乱，只是因为她26岁，他27岁。他们都很年轻，是黑人，在布鲁克林扎根。她喜欢索卡（soca）音乐。他的酒吧整晚播放索卡音乐。这看起来似乎他们不应该离得那么远。
Neil Drumming is one of the producers of our show.
尼尔·德拉明是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act Three, An Awful Place That You're Lucky to Get To. OK, so this is something that never really happens. We have a couple minutes left in the show. And I'm glad, because it lets me read you this thing that I like.
第三幕，一个你有幸到达的可怕地方。OK，这是从未真正发生过的事情。我们在节目中还有几分钟。我很高兴，因为它让我给你读这个我喜欢的东西。
This is kind of tangentially on theme with If You Build It, They Will Come. It's about old age, which, I guess, is a place that is built for us. And maybe we get there. I don't know. Don't think too hard about that.
这与“如果你盖好了，他们会来”在主题上有点关联。它是关于衰老，我想，那是一个为我们建立的地方。也许我们到了那里。我不知道。别太费劲想那个。
Donald Hall died a few weeks ago. He was on the show years back, and I knew him a tiny bit. He was a poet and writer, the poet laureate of the United States for a while. He wrote about lots of things.
唐纳德·霍尔（Donald Hall）几周前去世了。多年前他在节目中，我稍微认识他一点。他是一位诗人和作家，曾担任一段时间的美国桂冠诗人。他写过很多事情。
But in the last few years, he's been writing about old age in this utterly unsentimental, lucid way that I really, really love, like in this piece. This is from his book, Essays After 80.
但在过去的几年里，他一直以这种完全非感伤、清醒的方式写作关于衰老，我真的很喜欢，比如在这篇文章中。这来自他的书《80岁后的散文》（Essays After 80）。
"After a life of loving the old, by natural law, I turned old myself. Decade follows each other. 30 was terrifying. 40, I never noticed because I was drunk. 50 was best, with a total change of life. 60 extended the bliss of 50.
“在爱了一辈子老人之后，根据自然规律，我自己也变老了。十年接着十年。30岁是可怕的。40岁，我没注意到，因为我喝醉了。50岁是最好的，生活发生了彻底的改变。60岁延续了50岁的幸福。
Then came my cancers, Jane's death." Jane was his wife. "And over the years, I traveled to another universe. However alert we are, however much we think we know what will happen, antiquity remains an unknown, unanticipated galaxy.
然后是我的癌症，简的去世。”简是他妻子。“这些年来，我旅行到了另一个宇宙。无论我们多么警觉，无论我们认为我们多么知道会发生什么，古老仍然是一个未知的、未预料到的银河系。
It's alien. And old people are a separate form of life. They have green skin, with two heads that sprout antennae. They can be pleasant. They can be annoying. In the supermarket, those old ladies won't get out of my way.
它是陌生的。而老年人是另一种生命形式。他们有绿色的皮肤，长着两颗头，长着触角。他们可以是令人愉快的。他们可以是恼人的。在超市里，那些老太太不会从我路上让开。
Most important, they are permanently other. When we turn 80, we understand that we are extraterrestrial. If we forget for a moment that we're old, we're reminded when we try to stand up and when we encounter someone young, who appears to observe green skin, extra heads, and protuberances.
最重要的是，他们是永久的异类。当我们80岁时，我们明白我们是外星人。如果我们有一会儿忘记了我们老了，当我们试图站起来遇到一个年轻人时，就会被提醒，他似乎观察到了绿色的皮肤、多出的头和突起。
People's response to our separateness can be callous, can be good-hearted, and is always condescending. When a woman writes to the newspaper approving of something that I've done, she calls me a nice old gentleman. She intends to praise me with 'nice' and 'gentleman.' 'Old' is true enough. And she lets us know that I am not a grumpy old fart.
人们对我们独立性的反应可能是冷酷的，可能是善意的，而且总是居高临下的。当一位女士写信给报纸赞许我所做的事情时，她称我为一位好心的老绅士。她打算用“好心”和“绅士”来赞美我。“老”是足够真实的。她让我们知道我不是一个脾气暴躁的老屁。
But 'nice' and 'gentleman' put me in a box where she can rub my head and hear me purr. Or maybe she would prefer me to wag my tail, lick her hand, and make ingratiating dog noises."
但“好心”和“绅士”把我关在一个盒子里，在那里她可以摸摸我的头，听到我打呼噜。或者也许她更愿意让我摇尾巴、舔她的手，并发出讨好的狗叫声。”
Anyway, that's by Donald Hall, from his book, Essays After 80. He just published another book on the subject with the vivid name, A Carnival of Losses. I recommend both books, or especially his book, Without, which is poetry that he wrote when his wife, Jane Kenyon, died. Anyway, thanks, Donald.
总之，那是唐纳德·霍尔，来自他的书《80岁后的散文》。他刚刚出版了另一本关于这个主题的书，有着生动的名字《损失的嘉年华》（A Carnival of Losses）。我推荐这两本书，或者特别是他的书《没有》（Without），那是他在妻子简·凯尼恩（Jane Kenyon）去世时写的诗。总之，谢谢，唐纳德。
Our program was produced today by Alvin Melathe and Neil Drumming. People who helped make the show today-- Dana Chivvis, Jarrett Floyd, Damien Graef, Chana Joffe-Walt, David Kestenbaum, Seth Lind, Angelina Mosher, Lulu Miller, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Simeon, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, Sharif Youssef, Julie Whitaker, and Diane Wu. Our senior producer is Brian Reed. Our managing editor is Susan Burton.
我们今天的节目由阿尔文·梅拉特（Alvin Melathe）和尼尔·德拉明制作。今天帮助制作节目的人——达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、贾瑞特·弗洛伊德（Jarrett Floyd）、达米恩·格拉夫（Damien Graef）、查娜·乔夫-沃尔特（Chana Joffe-Walt）、大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）、塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）、安吉丽娜·莫舍（Angelina Mosher）、露露·米勒（Lulu Miller）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、罗宾·西蒙（Robyn Simeon）、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）、沙里夫·尤素福（Sharif Youssef）、朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）和黛安·吴（Diane Wu）。我们的高级制作人是布莱恩·里德（Brian Reed）。我们的执行编辑是苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）。
Special thanks today to Emma Whitford, Sai Mokhtari, Rebecca Birmingham, Simone Polanen, Sarah Sarahsen, Alex Blumberg, Peter Leonard, Lisa Pollak, and Haley Shaw, who did a lot of the music in our church story today. Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our archive of over 600 episodes for absolutely free. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange.
特别感谢今天的艾玛·惠特福德（Emma Whitford）、赛·莫赫塔里（Sai Mokhtari）、丽贝卡·伯明翰（Rebecca Birmingham）、西蒙·波拉宁（Simone Polanen）、萨拉·萨拉森（Sarah Sarahsen）、亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、彼得·伦纳德（Peter Leonard）、丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）和海莉·肖（Haley Shaw），他们今天在我们教会故事中做了很多音乐。我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费收听我们超过600集的档案。《This American Life》由 PRX（公共广播交易所）传送到公共广播电台。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[致谢]
Thanks as always to our program's cofounder, Mr. Torey Malatia. And now, he is so generous, he agreed to cater and also costar in Shonda Rhimes' new Netflix series about the music business--
一如既往感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。现在，他非常慷慨，他同意在珊达·莱梅斯（Shonda Rhimes）关于音乐产业的新 Netflix 系列中提供餐饮并联合主演——
Doing her a big-ass favor by making grits and playing Beyonce.
为她帮了一个大忙，做粗粮并播放碧昂丝的音乐。
I'm Ira glass, back next week with more stores of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《This American Life》的故事回来。
[MUSIC - "HOLD ON I'M COMING" BY SAM AND DAVE]
[音乐 - Sam and Dave 的《Hold On I'm Coming》]